of that hatch closure coming up here
shortly
now the team of flight controllers here
in Mission Control Houston are being led
by flight
two three and four Ollie will wait for
us to see that the next steps on the
heads this year
okay SpaceX copies good intercom checks
and can you repeat the second half of
that last
and you did hear the commander of the
Axiom 2 mission Peggy Whitson stepping
through some of those procedures doing
some communication checks ahead of that
hatch closure and undocking preparing
here shortly so the team of
check
so again the team here in Mission
Control Houston is working through some
of those communication checks with the
crew of Axiom 2.
right now there is some reconfiguration
going on with the communication system
but we do expect that reconfiguration to
be wrapped up here shortly and then
we'll be able to hear from the Axiom 2
crew once again
sounds good
Dragon SpaceX on the big loop I had you
five by five how me
now as the crew continues to step
through those communication checks we
are
everything looking good this morning as
far as weather is concerned for the
prime Splashdown Zone
Jason dragon how do you read
Dragon SpaceX on Dragon to ground
Comcheck
so the crew is continuing to step
through those communication checks and
the team here on Mission Control here in
mission control as well as in Mission
Control Hawthorne are configuring what
is called the big loop this is an
integrated Communications Loop between
the NASA and SpaceX and Axiom teams so
the space to ground Loops that you hear
on board the International Space Station
will be fully integrated with the
communications onboard SpaceX Dragon
freedom and you are getting a great view
right now from inside crew Dragon
Freedom that is the commander Peggy
Whitson as she works to put her gloves
on and step through those procedures
ahead of hatch closure
the crew did get suited up in their
launch and entry spacesuits earlier this
morning these spacesuits are worn during
all of the dynamic operations including
launch landing undocking and Splashdown
following hatch closure leak checks were
will occur and then we'll look ahead to
an undocking at 10 05 a.m central time
this morning will be about a 12 hour
Journey for the Axiom 2 crew
there are several Landing sites that the
teams are monitoring for weather and the
prime Landing site as of this morning is
Panama City
business station on two and we're
standing by uh waiting on three decimal
five
for uh picking up in our steps
Houston copies
and that was the voice of NASA astronaut
Steve Bowen who is going to take the
prime responsibility for monitoring the
departure of dragon
earlier this is
Dragon this is Houston we have you on
the big loop
okay great
and Peggy we
are figuring our our
end so it'll be another 10 15 minutes or
so before you can talk to ISS from
dragon
hey thanks
um and we whenever you're ready we're uh
at two decimal ten for uh dragons
Houston copies
so again the crew is working through
those procedures ahead of the hatch
opening and part of that includes making
sure that the integrated big loop is
configured properly
once that Loop is configured correctly
we'll have some communication checks on
board the spacecraft
and we are working two decimal eight
right now
copy Peggy good to hear from you and I
think I copied your last it was that
you're through 2.10 cabin configuration
is that a good read
I'd say uh so we must continue to say
anything here in the cabin so we're two
decimal eight
okay SpaceX copies you're at 2.8 and
we'll be back with you in 2.10
we're continuing to get good views
inside crew Dragon freedom
Peggy Whitson as you see there in the
middle of your screen is the commander
of crew Dragon freedom
this is her fourth space flight and by
the time she splashes down later today
she will have a cumulative
674 days spent in space
and to the right of Peggy is the pilot
John shoffner
this is his first space flight
alongside the crew freedom is also
bringing home about 300 pounds of
Science and hardware and over 20 science
experiments at the Axiom 2 crew worked
on throughout their stay on board the
International Space Station
this is the second time that crew Dragon
Freedom has gone to space the first was
last year as part of the crew 4 Mission
to the left of John schoffner's head you
can see the mission patch for that crew
4 Mission
and we're getting another view of one of
the other crew members inside Freedom
that is Rihanna Barney
this is also her first space flight
and as you can see the crew is stepping
through and reviewing procedures on the
tablet that they have on their leg
SpaceX dragging Road steps are now ready
for a dragon 7 configuration for the
cards are complete
copy Dragon 2 1.10 at this time you are
go for 2.103 all of Section 3 for lyo
install imv duct teardown and hatch
closure we're going to have you unseal
and reinstall wire cartridge one in the
active cartridge slot how copy
yeah we copy step three oh
okay
and dragon want to make sure you copied
Leo cartridge one
oh thank you live
all right
okay Dragon and one more set of
instructions when you're complete with
Section 3 pick up in the hatch closed
event detail and complete suit donning
hatch close event details and Suites on
it
you got it Peggy thanks
and you just heard Peggy Whitson talking
with the SpaceX Mission director about
some of the procedures including
lyokanisters that's lithium hydroxide
canisters which are responsible for
scrubbing carbon dioxide in the dragon
cabin throughout the transit from the
International Space Station back to
Earth
again for this undocking the transit
time is a little more than 12 hours and
we are targeting off the coast of Panama
City for today's Splashdown
here in Mission Control Houston will
continue to track as Axiom Works their
way through these procedures
we'll cover live on air through hatch
closure this morning then we'll take a
brief break while leak checks occur and
then we'll be back on the air with both
Axiom and SpaceX for undocking coverage
and SpaceX Dragon uh on the big loop at
1316 lyo Partridge one was installed
SpaceX copies lyo cartridge one
installed at 1316. you are still go for
imv duck teardown and hatch closure
and dragon copies will continue
three decimal five
hearing good call outs with the
installation of that lithium hydroxide
canister again that scrubs carbon
dioxide from the dragon during the 12
hour Transit
this is required because once the
hatches are closed between dragon and
the International Space Station and the
umbilicals disconnect and the dragon
vehicle undocks
Dragon Freedom will no longer be able to
rely on the atmosphere from inside the
International Space Station
so it will be up to the dragon Freedom
environmental control and life support
systems for the journey home
and we are beginning to see the hatch
close there in your screen
Ali our Kearney continuing to work on
getting that hatch closed
as you can see here he's not quite
suited up in his launch and re-entry
suit yet but once that hatch is closed
he'll work on getting that spacesuit on
CE the hatches are closed it takes about
an hour for leak checks to occur
and a thumbs up from Ali
SpaceX dragons
and figures
is closed
copy Dragon hatch closed we've got a
command here that will send imminently
to transition the state machine
reference the hatch closed event detail
and I think you already know this but it
continues suit donning
I will continue
and we just heard confirmation from the
Axiom to Commander Peggy Whitson
the hatches are closed the hatches
between SpaceX Dragon freedom and the
International Space Station were closed
at 8 20 a.m central time this morning
now a sequence of events will occur in
between our coverage which we're going
to wrap up here shortly Houston on the
big loop for a comp check
we have you loud and clear as well we
have configured RF
and would like you to initiate comchecks
with ISS and SpaceX at this time
fabulous and station uh dragons how do
you read soundtrack
[Music]
dragon how do you read
Dragon SpaceX we've got you five by five
all right we have to get a lot of Sarah
as well
so again the hatch on the crew Dragon
Freedom was closed this morning at 8 20
a.m Central Time
but there is one more hatch that needs
to close and that's on the International
Space Station side NASA astronaut Steve
Bowen will be working to get that hatch
closed this is called the a-pass hatch
he'll then make sure to take some photos
of the hatch once it's closed to make
sure there's no fod or foreign object
object debris to ensure that the hatch
has an airtight seal before he continues
to methodically step
through the process to get the hatch
closed and then work through deep the
depressurization sequence
once the two hatches are closed it's
going to create an area in between the
two hatches which we call the vestibule
once that vestibule is immediately
created it will be at space station
pressure about 14 pounds per square inch
but we do need to get that vestibule
down to zero
a
French version
Houston copies SSC 12. thank you
so in order to get the vestibule down to
vacuum
we will depressurize it that that
process does take about an hour we won't
be on air monitoring that this morning
but we will come back on following
depressurization ahead of undocking
everything's still looking good this
morning for an on-time undocking at 10
05 a.m Central
that is the session just a quick
question uh corrected on the flashcard I
used it was seal number 1110.
we copy 11 10.
and if you're just joining us this
morning you're getting a live view
inside the SpaceX crew Dragon Freedom
which has four private astronauts on
board
the hatch to crew Dragon freedom is
closed and we are awaiting hatch closure
on board the International Space Station
ahead of undocking later this morning
Axiom 2 launched on Sunday May 21st from
the Kennedy Space Center in Florida and
docked to the International Space
Station the following day on May 22nd
during their nine days in Space the crew
has been working on over 20 different
science experiments
Dragon SpaceX on the big loop for cabin
temperature control
hey Peggy just some awareness we
commanded the hex bypass to allow crew
control just now it's on the maximum
cooling setting and a reminder that the
temp control is allowed with 4.080 until
pre-chill prior to de-orbit
if you control the 4.080 until pre-kill
for uh
good copy
and you're looking at a view from inside
the International Space Station as NASA
astronaut Steve Bowen Works through
those procedures to get the hatch closed
on the space station side
once that is done it will create that
space we were talking about earlier the
vestibule which will ultimately be
depressure depressurized before we can
have our undocking later this morning at
10 05 a.m Central
and as Bowen moves the camera slightly
you can see a good view of one of the
spacesuits on board the International
Space Station that's the exploration
Mobility unit or emu
we actually have a spacewalk coming up
on June 9th with Steve Bowen and Woody
hoberg
they'll be working to install an
upgraded irosa or International Space
Station roll out solar array on the 1A
power Channel
and you just saw Woody hoberg Float by
in the screen there as well
and you're also seeing a view of NASA
astronaut Frank Rubio in the screen
there
Frank Rubio is in the midst of a long
duration space flight AS are all the
crew on board the International Space
Station
however when Rubio lands in September he
will have spent a total of 371 days in
Space the longest cumulative time for
any NASA astronaut
crew on board is continuing to configure
everything ahead of that hatch closure
that bag that you see Bowen zipping up
now is what we call a cargo transfer bag
and this shot from inside crew Dragon
Freedom again the crew continuing to
step through those procedures
the hatch is closed on crew Dragon
freedom but we are just waiting for the
hatch to be closed on the International
Space Station side
as you can see the crew is suited up in
their spacesuits the launch and entry
spacesuit which is worn during all of
the dynamic phases of the mission
including launch docking undocking and
re-entry and Splashdown
[Music]
copy Dragon four crew members suited
seated and with good intercom checks at
this time you are go for 4.011 suit leak
check all of section one and we'll meet
you in 2.2
and we are starting in on uh 4.011 and
now
and you do see the crew inside Freedom
putting their visors down this is going
to be part of the procedures to step
through those suit leak checks
this is a precautionary measure just to
ensure everything is looking good on the
spacesuits ahead of undocking
the spacesuits do provide an extra layer
of protection during the dynamic phases
of the mission it'll be about a 12 hour
Transit from undocking to Splashdown
today the crew will have the opportunity
to remove those spacesuits and get a
little bit more comfortable following
undocking
and again we are targeting Splashdown
off the coast of Florida near Panama
City
everything looking good for an on-time
Splashdown this morning at 10 05 a.m
Central
and another
we are ready to pressurized steps
copy Dragon we're with you you are go to
initiate suit leak check
so just a quick recap of where we're at
right now earlier this morning at 8 20
a.m Central the hatch to crew Dragon
Freedom was successfully closed at this
time we're awaiting the closure of the
hatch on board the International Space
Station side that apas hatch you see
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen continuing to
work through procedures ahead of that
hatch closure
following this the vestibule will be
depressurized this process takes about
an hour and then assuming all goes well
crew Dragon Freedom will undock at 1005
a.m central time this morning
we're targeting a Splashdown off the
coast of Panama City Florida this
evening around 1004 PM Central
as Steve Bowen continues to work through
those procedures to get the apas hatch
close the International Space Station
it looks like we have four good seats
copy Dragon we see the same for good
suits next up is vestibule depress stand
by just a few minutes while ground teams
confirm we're ready for that
is
and hearing from Axiom 2 Commander Peggy
Whitson that four good lead checks
occurred inside the crew Dragon freedom
again Steve Bowen is continuing to step
through those procedures to get the
a-pass hatch closed the International
Space Station is currently flying 270
statute miles over the Pacific Ocean
just off the coast of New Zealand
and continuing to get a view inside crew
Dragon Freedom you're looking at the
commander Peggy Whitson in the middle of
your screen and to her right is the
pilot John schnaufner
also on board are are all Carney and
Rihanna Barney we
both of whom are representing this the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
and getting a slightly different shot
from inside crew Dragon this one of
Rihanna Barney on your left and pilot
John schoffner to to her left
and we are continuing to await the go
for the apas hatch closure
we are in a brief expected Handover
between satellites but we'll regain
video and Communications with the
International Space Station here shortly
once NASA astronaut Steve Bowen has the
go to close the hatch that apass hatch
he'll step through the procedures to get
that completed
following the closure of the hatch he'll
work to take some photographs of the
hatch to ensure that there's no fod or
foreign object debris
and once this is complete it'll have the
go to begin the depressurization process
again that process takes about an hour
and it brings that space between the
crew Dragon freedom and the
International Space Station hatches that
space that is created called the
vestibule down to vacuum
this is required before the crew dragon
undocks from the International Space
Station
still targeting an on-time undocking
this morning at 10 05 a.m Central
and you're getting a view of the
International Space Station flight
control room here in Houston Texas the
teams here Dragon SpaceX Comcheck on
dragging to ground
it's dragon dragon
hey John had you five by five just
checking that we had this one working
before we undock uh still working on
closing the apas hatch but we'll get
back to you on the big loop here shortly
for vestibule depress
ing copies will be right here
and that was the voice of pilot John
schoffner speaking to the ground just a
quick update that they are still working
to get that a-pass hatch closed on the
International Space Station side and
following that they'll step through the
procedures for that vestibule
depressurization
and as we look ahead to undocking at
1005 a.m Central this will actually be a
five minute sequence once the command is
initiated
once that command is set it begins the
retraction of umbilicals that have been
providing power and Communications data
in between the crew Dragon freedom and
the International Space Station
right now the dragon is being held to
the International Space Station by a
hard mate of 12 hooks
those will be released six at a time to
release any stiction
what they'll do is have a couple of
undocking burns these are very short
pulses to actually physically separate
the dragon from the International Space
Station
physical separation again scheduled for
1005 a.m central time this morning
continuing to get a view inside the
International Space Station flight
control room
the team here is working with both Axiom
and SpaceX to oversee the operations
that we're covering right now
following exit of the approach ellipsoid
those integrated operations will
discontinue and it will really be up to
SpaceX and Axiom to get crew Dragon
Freedom home from there
and you are seeing some flash there as
NASA astronaut Steve Bowen gathers some
imagery of the hatch
again he's checking to ensure that
there's no faud or foreign object debris
that could pose a problem prior to
undocking
and we are getting a view back inside
the crew Dragon Freedom you see Rihanna
Barney there as well as the pilot John
schoffner
on board space station NASA astronaut
Steve bone is continuing to step through
those procedures to get the hatch close
the a-pass hatch rather closed here
shortly
once he does that that will wrap up our
coverage our solo Mission coverage here
in Mission Control Houston but we'll be
back on the air to cover undocking as
well as the
to cover undocking with SpaceX and Axiom
station
Houston Loop this is for Steve you are
go at 5 decimal three to close the a
patch a pass hatch when you get there
and here's the station just completed
the hatch seal inspection and I am going
to close the apath hatch
we copy
and hearing that Steve Bowen has
inspected the hatch closure and has the
go from the ground to go ahead and close
up that a-pass hatch
once those hatches are closed between
both Freedom which already is closed and
the a pass hatch will create that
vestibule
currently it's at the same pressure of
the International Space Station just
above 14 pounds per square inch but we
do need to get it all the way down to
vacuum
this depressurization is a very
methodical process which takes about an
hour
here in Mission Control Houston will
continue to monitor that while we're off
air
and you do see that a pass hatch is now
closed
we are still on track for an untimely
undocking today at 10 05 a.m Central
this morning
so with both the crew Dragon Freedom
hatch closed and the apas hatch that
will do it for us for now here in
Mission Control Houston but we'll be
back on the air joined by SpaceX and
Axiom for undocking coverage at 9 45 a.m
Central so stay tuned for our coverage
of that we'll be covering the operations
as the undocking occurs and Axiom 2
heads back home after a nine-day mission
in space so until then thank you for
joining us for hatch closure coverage
and we'll see you soon for undocking
coverage this is Mission Control Houston